welcome back now employers are being
urged to review their bereavement leave
policy as part of this year's pregnancy
and infant loss remembrance day it comes
after a campaign aimed at getting bosses
to commit to supporting their staff
through the distress of miscarriage one
company that's announcing a new
pregnancy loss policy today is flow
health a period and ovulation tracker
app for joining me now to talk about
this is anne roberts she's chief people
officer at flow and claudia pasted she's
the company's medical advisor uh welcome
to you both um claudia let me start with
uh with you i mean how widespread is
pregnancy loss
yeah it's incredibly widespread it's
actually much more common pregnancy loss
is far more common than we realize
and if we speak about miscarriage for
example for which the definition varies
across the world but in the uk it's the
loss of a pregnancy during the first 23
weeks
one in eight known pregnancies end in
miscarriage
and the reality beyond this number is we
often don't know that our friend or our
colleague is going through this
experience and not everybody finds it
easy to talk about it either
so we know that no matter the nature of
the loss the moment when it happens its
effects can be profound and long-lasting
and it affects everybody differently too
so 30 to 50 percent of people who have
miscarried might experience anxiety 10
to 15 percent depression and also one in
six women who have a miscarriage or
ectopic pregnancy experience long-term
post-traumatic stress so it's important
to support people at the time of their
loss but also beyond that after and
that's what we hope to achieve with that
with our pregnancy loss policy
so ann what are you going to be changing
what's going to be new about what you do
um so we're going to be introducing um a
pregnancy loss policy that includes
anybody who is going through the
experience regardless of their service
whether in the world what stage of
pregnancy they're in
whether they're the expecting mother or
the partner
to be able to take two weeks off no
questions asked self-certified leave
fully paid um also including more
support in return to work and more
resources for both employees going
through the experience and
their managers and their colleagues on
on how to support um and create an
empathetic environment in the workplace
for this
and will that policy be extended to
employees who've gone through an
abortion
or is it just confined to those who've
had a miscarriage
yes it includes anybody who is going
through abortion um as well as if it
happens to a baby surrogate mother if
you're a surrogate parent
claudia you mentioned just now that this
is not something that is is widely
talked about why do you think that is
because i mean i imagine everyone
watching this program i certainly do
know someone who's been through a
miscarriage
yeah that's right i mean there is i
think lots of us are aware of this idea
that you you can't you feel like you
can't talk about your pregnancy until
you've had your scan at 12 weeks and we
know that most miscarriages actually
happen before 12 weeks so there seems to
be sort of this idea that you don't talk
about and therefore when a miscarriage
happens in that period of time you you
have nobody to turn to or to speak to
about it so i think that's that's
possibly something that's contributing
to it it's astonishing that there are as
many miscarriages in the world as there
are these days given the advances that
we've seen in medical technology
yes but there are certain things like
this that that
we can't stop and unfortunately can't
always prevent about 70 percent of
miscarriages actually happen because of
chromosomal abnormalities and these
aren't really things that we know how to
prevent or to stop unfortunately
so and why is it do are there many other
companies out there that you're aware of
that have a pregnancy loss policy like
the one you've introduced
uh
yes we're not complete pioneers in the
field um we're
um trailblazing um
along with uh four other companies and
that i know of in the uk who have
introduced this
um and i'm
certain that with the pandemic and the
increased focus on
mental health well-being
creating supportive workplaces friend
please you know
long gone are the days of the 2000s
where
the employer value proposition was about
free booze and bouncy castles in office
um the conversation in the industry for
employers let's move on to how do you
create an inclusive workplace that
recognizes that people have a life
outside of their work
and making a meaningful impact in that
support um so i'm seeing the trend
continuing for for businesses
well hopefully the fact that you've come
on today to talk about this might
encourage a few more businesses to to
follow your example uh i mean tell me
about the business how's the business
going right now
um so um flow is the world's most
popular um health and witness fitness
app um we have over 43 million active
million
active users 1.6 million of them are in
the uk alone
the business is growing incredibly
strongly
and that's off the back of their
heightened awareness in society
about
about menstrual health about supporting
women from
uh early stages of motherhood or from
first getting administration all the way
to menopause um so the focus on on
reproductive health and female health is
is incredibly
um growing field and off the back of
that where we're leading the empowerment
of women around the world so business is
doing very well
good to hear well congratulations on a
very worthy initiative and claudia good
to talk to you both this morning thank
you